دراسة الصمت
والعنف اللذين تخللتهما هذه
هي المهمة هنا في استطلاع جنوب هوليا
حيث تنتظر الحياة في الأنقاض
هجوم أوكرانيا المضاد لإخراج
الروس من فضاءهم الذي
لم تتركه ميلر منذ بدء الحرب
ويعرف أن مدفعيتها
هي  كل ما كان عليهم فعله أثناء انتظارهم
هنا مع راديو فقط
يقولون إنه جلب أفضل أخبارهم ، لكن في
هذا اليوم علموا أن الروس
قصفوا أنفسهم بالصدفة في بيلجارد
مؤخرًا تعتقد نينا أنها لاحظت
تغيرًا في الانفجارات
الآن
الدافع الأجنبي  في السهول في وقت سابق من هذا
الأسبوع ، وتوجد إشارات في
المسارات في Booms تشير إلى أن أوكرانيا قد
تستهدف الجنوب لفصل شبه جزيرة القرم عن
روسيا ،
يكون الصوت مرتفعًا تمامًا
حيث يطلق الروس النار من مسافة قريبة بواسطة
مشغلين بدون طيار يطيرون في الفجوات بين
التشويش الإلكتروني في  هذه الحقول المفتوحة
هنا كل جانب يحاول تحديد الآخر
يضعف الآخر قبل هذا
الهجوم المضاد.
طريق واحد هو هدفهم ،
السيارات ، التغييرات الصغيرة وعلامات
الضعف ، هل يستعدون للهجوم
المضاد أو لا يفعلون شيئًا.
لا تفعل ذلك أبدًا ،
ترك فخًا مفخخًا أجنبيًا خلفك ، ليس من الواضح ما إذا كان
الروس الذين يواجهونهم الآن لديهم
تجربة مماثلة
بعد 90 دقيقة ، يتم استبدال كل مظلات من دون طيار
مرة أخرى قريبًا
بقذيفة بقعة طيران أخرى وكرر
الانتظار وستنتهي المشاهدة قريبًا